marrant en parlant de poursuites parce
que tu as eu une histoire avec doc
gynéco il paraît qu'un jour il ya une
histoire d'amour de baston avec doc
gynéco tu sais que c'est une dizaine
d'années j'ai joué le dock est bon et je
suis déjà veloso que c'est quand même
celui du texte sont les répliques
c'était dur moi je m'en souviens
j'arrivais toiletter son canapé et sa
table et sa phrase fait feu s'ils
disaient il viendra pas à fuser
ah oui oui est-ce qu'il va venir c'est
certain il va partir à traire alors
isolée de l'île devait venir ici par un
très léger
ils vont partir en train dit oui est ce
qu'il préfère dans le tas et je n'y vais
jamais j'avais nous ne te du mois de
jeûne d'armes tous avec la pierre de
casquettes voit une casquette à la tenue
tout ça et je joue où j'étais avec
lelouch philippe lellouche tient aux
jeux sur scène ce total du gymnase thé
café de monde était vraiment et je vois
derrière moi pas si nous tenaillait tout
le travail lopez et j'en rigole toi et
moi je savais que c'était pas dans la
pièce interdite après passe est très tôt
ses tréteaux et leur fille qui se casse
la gueule et là j'attendais les vives
avant ça les filles qui étaient les
autres actrices qui étaient en coulisses
estevelles saint vincent et l'autre il
c'était un bocal et avait 2 2 mecs
étaient arrivées qui lui file une salade
dans les torgnoles il se battait avec
deux mecs nanquette arriver donc moi
chaque écoute and common enthousiasme je
l' ai vu qui était quand même
comme il devait le curé il y avait du
coeur à l'ouvragé arriver mais disons
que le bon là je ne m'en étais pas mais
qui avait pris qui le trénel autres
limiter les pilotes non c'est pas vrai
moi ils sont arrivés j'ai fusillé le
premier toit alors à la régulière par
derrière
le problème a pris à mouiller et donc
moi qui avais un peu les yeux là la
chemise arrachée à nommer annoncé
demande de lui c'est sérieux dont il
avait les cheveux comme ça il a une
bonne et il était mieux mais la pièce
après et donc quel est le problème après
nous a poursuivi un peu comme on a vu
qu'on prenait le dessus les à finir
l'année masques ou de pop et est donc là
le producteur vient me voir dominique
aube du china on peut pas reprendre le
rideau était tombé sous toit comment ça
on reprend pas je suis remonté j'avais
lâché là qu'est ce qu'être arraché comme
ça j'avais l'oeil comme ça la chemise
arrachée
si ça manque un peu de sécurité issia et
l'autre n'étaient par dessus la chemise
homme seul j'ai vu des mecs cependant
que tu joues tu as un comédien qui se
bat en coulisses